[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم
مشاهدينا الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء
واسرائيل وبالمنصه صواريخ لا تهدئه ولا
التزام بالتعهدات هل تنظر جوله التصعيد
بتفجر كامل للاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
الازمه السودانيه تقترب من الشهر اشتباكات
لا تتوقف وتفاؤل حذر في اروقه المحادثات
بين تضارب المشهد والتصريحات كيف سيكون
حلو الازمه
وانواب اوروبيون يعتزمون فرض قواعد
تنظيميه على استخدام تقنيه
فهل تنهي هذه القواعد الجدل الدائر بشان
مستقبل قطع الذكاء الاصطناعي
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الاول
هدوء مقابل هدوء في غزه هو مطلب اسرائيل
لوقف النار الذي افتتحته تل ابيب باغتيال
ثلاثه من ابرز القيادات العسكريه لحركه
الجهات قبل يومين الموقف الاسرائيلي
يقابله اشتراط حركه الجهاد وقف اسرائيل
لسياسه الاغتيالات مقابل وقف النار
وبانتظار نتيجه المطالب يعم غزه هدوء
متوتر تخترقه ضربات متبادله محسوبه بين
الطرفين اسرائيل صعدت من موقفها ورفضت
شرطه حركه حماس واختلت المسؤول عن اداره
الوحده الصاروخيه للحركه علي غالي كما
واصلت اغلاق الحواجز والمعابر الى قطع غزه
والذي فرضته
حركه الجهاد من جهتها وصلت اطلاق الصواريخ
باتجاه الاراضي الاسرائيليه وتوعدت بالرد
على مقتل علي غالي الذي استهدفته اسرائيل
استهدفت افراد كذلك من عائلته الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال ان الحركه اطلقت اكثر من
صاروخ تجاه اسرائيل منذ بدء التصعيد
اعترضت القبه الحديديه ثلث منها تقريبا
هذا ولم تعلن تل ابيب عن قتيل في المقابل
قتل في قطاع غزل عشرات منهم مدنيون من
اغلبهم اطفال وتعليقا على هذه التطورات
حتى وزراء خارجيه كل مصر والاردن وفرنسا
والمانيا لانهاء اعمال العنف بين اسرائيل
وغسان
[موسيقى]
في وقت سابق من صباح اليوم قمنا باغتيال
قائد مجموعه صواريخ الجهات في غزه والان
منذ فتره وجيزه اختلنا نائبه ايضا اي شخص
ياتي ليؤذينا لن يجني سوى الدم على راسه
هو ومن يحل محله نحن في منتصف المعركه في
الهجوم والدفاع وسنواصل التقدم لحمايه
سمائنا وحياه مواطنينا
كرات مع ضيوفنا
مره محلله السياسي ومن حيفا يؤذى المحلله
السياسي كذلك اهلا بكم الى نقاش فانوراما
لهذا المساء واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من حيفا
معك
في الواقع حركه الجهاد اوجعت اسرائيل في
الساعات الاخيره استهدفت عسقلان استهدفت
ديروط جنوب تل ابيب واوقعت قتيل هل يمكن
القول بان اسرائيل تخلت عن امنها الداخلي
لاسباب او لاهداف سياسيه
لا اعتقد هكذا اعتقد انه اسرائيل اختاره
تبادر في هذه العمليه
واغتالت ثلاثه من اهم القيادات في الجهاد
الاسلامي وبعد ذلك كمان اثنين
اعتقد انه ليس هناك افق لهذه العمليات
يعني استراتيجيا لا فائده منها ولكن لا
اعتقد انه اسرائيل تخلتا امنها داخلي
اعتقد ان اسرائيل امنه نسبيا اعتقد انه
الجوله جوله العنف مستمره واحنا مقبلين
هناك اعلان لجهاد الاسلامي انه بعد اقل من
الان سيكون هناك وابل اخر من الصواريخ
باتجاه اسرائيل اسرائيل اثبتت انها قادره
التصدي لمثل هذه الصواريخ
وصدر سياسي حاله ولكن هذا يكلفها هي
تعترضها ولكن يكلفها الملايين يكلفها
الملايين مقابل صواريخ تصنع يدويا في داخل
غزه
هذا صحيح هذا صحيح ولكن ليس هناك اي دوله
اخرى في العالم تمتلك هذه القدرات نعم هي
غاليه جدا ولكن اسرائيل حاليا تستطيع ان
تدفع هذا الثمن هي مستعده ان تستثمر مثل
هذه الاموال لحمايه حياه مواطنيها
انا اعتقد انه يعني الاشي المؤسف الامر
المؤسف هنا انه حتى يوم الرد وبعد غد سنصل
الى المربى الاول هو فقط مساله كم من شخص
يدفع بحياته من اجل الوصول الى المربى
الاول اعتقد انه لا فائده من هذه الجولات
من العنف وانما فقط شراء الوقت الى الجوله
القادمه هل تتفق استاذ محمد مع ضيفي بانه
في النهايه ستكون هناك عوده رغم سقوط
القتلى من الجانبين ستكون هناك عوده
للمربع الاول ام انك ترى بان هذه
المواجهات هي تختلف تماما عن سابقتها
اعتقد بان ضيفك محق يعني فيما يتعلق بانه
بان الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه في هذا
المجال لا يوجد اهداف استراتيجيه لدى
اسرائيل في قطاع غزه وبان اسرائيل بدات
هذه الجوله بالاغتهالات من دون اي يعني
مبرر على الاطلاق وبانها ستعود الى نفس
النقطه وللاسف الشديد يعني سبب المشكلات
كل كل سبب المشكلات بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين ان الحكومات الاسرائيليه
المتعاقبه لا تعترف بالشعب الفلسطيني ولا
تعترف بحقوق للشعب الفلسطيني ولا تجد اي
مقاربات سياسيه
للمشكله مع الفلسطينيين وفقط لديها مقاربه
امنيه واحده وعسكريه واحده تعتقد بان او
تصنف كل فلسطيني باعتباره ارهابي ويشكل
خطر على اسرائيل وبان حق الفلسطيني في طلب
الحريه وطلب التحرر وطلب اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه الى جانب دوله اسرائيل هذا طلب
ارهابي وهذا طلب غير مقبول وغير مفهوم على
الاطلاق وبالتالي يعني اتفق مع مع ضيفك
بان بان المساله ستعود ما لم تكن هناك
يعني مقاربه سياسيه لهذه القضيه ستعود
المسائل الى نفس النقطه
سنكرر هذه يعني المواجهه بعد شهر بعد
شهرين بعد اسبوع بعد اسبوعين بعد سنه في
كل سنه نجد يعني انفسنا في عالقين في هذا
لان اسرائيل ترفض التفاوض السياسي على
مستقبل العلاقه بين الشعبين وليس ولا يهم
هذه الحكومات المتعاقبه للاسف الا يعني
استقرار هذه الحكومه واعاده بعض افراد هذه
الحكومه الى الى يعني المربع مربع الحكومه
الاولي ويعني هناك يعني ادعاءات لا اساس
لها على الاطلاق لان اسرائيل ليس لها
اهداف استراتيجيه في قطاع غزه سوى ان
تنتزع من الفلسطينيين حق المقاومه وحق
التضامن مع الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه
الذين تقوم اسرائيل بجيشها
بمحاصره الم الفلسطينيه بمعاقبه
الفلسطينيين جميعا اذا يعني اذا اذا صدر
من اي فلسطيني عمل مقاوم تقوم بمعاقبه كل
الشعب الفلسطيني وهذا امر يعني غير ليست
لديها اهداف استراتيجيه داخل قطاع غزه
ولكن قد يقول البعض بانه الاغتيالات هي في
صلب المنهجيه الاسرائيليه خاصه وان هناك
تصريحات سياسيه بذلك وهنا سؤال
لكثير يقول ان الوقت حان للاغتيالات
نتنياهو يقول نحن في ذروه المعركه
والتصعيد قد يكون متعدد الجبهات هل نفهم
بان الموضوع حضرتك لانه منذ قليل قلت بانه
خلال يومين او ثلاثه سنعود للمربع الاول
ستهدا الامور ولكن نحن نتابع بان
التصريحات هناك تصعيد في التصريحات من
الجانب الاسرائيلي كيف يفسر ذلك
نعم انا اريد ان اعلق على هذا واقول بانه
ما نراه الان يعني في الايام الاخيره في
اليومين الاخيرين هو مواجهه مباشره ما بين
اسرائيل وجهاد الاسلامي لم ينضم لهذه
المعركه احد غير الجهاد الاسلامي لا طبعا
ليس حماس ولكن ايضا ليس جماهير الفلسطينيه
ليس في الضفه الغربيه وليس في في داخل
اسرائيل ولكن تعلم حضرتك بانه مع استمرار
هذه الاشتباكات قد ينفلت الوضع في اي لحظه
صحيح 100% صحيح ولهذا السبب اسرائيل ساعه
نوعا ما حسب ما نفهم الى نهايه هذه
العمليه كانت معنيه بان تصل الامور الى
التفهمات لا نعرف تفاصيل عدم
عدم الموافقه ولكن مصر اعلنت اليوم انها
يعني ليس
لا تدخل على الخط مثل ما كان عليه الوضع
في اليومين الاخيرين هذا يعني انه احنا
مقبلين على استمرار النار وهناك مخاطره
تاخذ اسرائيل العاطقها في هذا انضمام
حماسي للمعركه سيكون مختلف تماما سنرى
كميات مختلفه من الصواريخ هذا مئه بالمئه
صحيح وبهذا لبنك فير الذي يتحدث فقط عن
اغتيالات بدون اي افق سياسي ليس لديه
استراتيجيه الى الاستعمال القوه والمزيد
من القوه واسرائيل
هو وزير يتبع لحكومه نتنياهو تصريحاته قد
تكون مؤسسه على شيء ما وهنا سؤال استاذ
محمد هل تعتقد بانه هذا التصريح لبنك كثير
وكذلك حتى تصريحات نتنياهو التصعيديه
يدفعها انقسام داخل اسرائيل هكذا يقول
مراقبون كيف هي قراءتك لهذا الموضوع
لا اعتقد يعني بان الخلافات الداخليه في
اسرائيل يعني هي سبب المشكلات مع
الفلسطينيين السبب هو عدم اعتراف اسرائيل
والاحزاب الاسرائيليه والنخبه الاسرائيليه
بحق الشعب الفلسطيني في اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه الى جانب اسرائيل ورفض التسويه
التفاوضيه ورفض اي يعني مقاربات سياسيه
للعلاقه مع الفلسطينيه هذا هو السبب
المباشر لكل يعني المواجهات التي تتم بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وسبب يعني وجود
يعني صراعات مسلحه في كل في كل لحظه وفي
كل مناسبه وفي كل منطقه الضفه الغربيه
مشتعله هناك اكثر من 100 شهيد فلسطيني منذ
بدايه العام في في مدن الضفه الغربيه
وقراها يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي يوميا في
اطار روتين الاحتلال اليومي وفي اطار
منظومه التحكم والسيطره الاستعماريه
الاسرائيليه بالشعب الفلسطيني في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه يقوم حرفيا
بعمليات قتل بعمليات اعتقال بعمليات
اجتياح بعمليات روتينيه حتى لو لم تكن
هناك اسباب موجبه للقيام بدوريات داخل
المدن الفلسطينيه ليقول الجيش الاسرائيلي
بان الكلمه العليا في هذه المنطقه له اي
بمعنى ان الاحتلال مؤبد في هذه المنطقه
ولا يجوز لاي احد ان يعترض على الاحتلال
هذا هو المنطق الاساسي الذي يرفضه
الفلسطينيون ويقاومون على اساسه قوات
الاحتلال يطالبون المستوى السياسي
الفلسطيني يطالب بمفاوضات لانهاء الاحتلال
واسرائيل تدير الظاهر لاي مطالبات من هذا
النوع وهذا
الحوار الوحيد هو حوار النار حوار القتل
حوار حوار من خلال الطائرات الاف 35 والاف
16 والاف 15 والصواريخ والمدفعيه
والدبابات وعمليات القتل اليوميه في
الشوارع من دون محاكمات وعمليات الاستيطان
المتسعه بصوره دائمه وايضا التهديدات
الاسرائيليه
يعني بحسم الموقف هناك حزبان في هذه
الحكومه يقولان بضروره الحسم مع
الفلسطينيين واستكمال يعني ما عجزت
اسرائيل عن تنفيذه في عام 1948 بمعنى ان
تسيطر اسرائيل بالكامل على ما تسميه بين
هلالين ارض فلسطين ارض اسرائيل الكامله
وهي ارض فلسطين الكامله التاريخيه وهذا
وهذا خلاف بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وايضا يعني استكمال ما عجزت عن تنفيذه بعد
احتلال اسرائيل للاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله عام 67
وبالتالي بالتالي يعني منطق الحسم من قبل
الحزبين الرئيسيين في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذا المنطق يعني مخالف للقانون الدولي
ومخالف للقانون الدولي الانساني ومخالف
للمنطق ومخالف للعقلانيه الذي اتسمت بها
يعني المجتمعات
الغربيه والمجتمعات الحضاريه التي يعني
تعتبر اسرائيل تشارك الحرب في هذه القيم
وبالتالي هناك غياب للعداله بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين
وبسبب غياب العداله بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
وجود مقاربه امنيه وعسكريه فقط بالنسبه
لاسرائيل في التعامل مع الفلسطينيين
فينفجر الوضع الوضع منفجر اصلا
وامتداد لما يجري في الضفه الغربيه لما
يجري من
تطور ولكن اسمح لي فقط استاذ
نشارك كذلك او نشرك كذلك ضيفنا معنا
هو يقول بانه اسرائيل التي تروج بانها
ديمقراطيه وبانها تحفظ حقوق الانسان هي
على الواقع لا تفعل ذلك بل عكس ذلك وهذا
لن يطرح منطق لحل الازمه هذا المنطق ليس
مؤسس لحل حقيقي للازمه بل انه سيد خل
المنطقه في المزيد من التطورات في المزيد
من التصعيد ولن يفت حتى الداخل الاسرائيلي
بشيء ما رايك
رايي انه بالنسبه للفلسطينيين اسرائيل
بالفعل ليس ديمقراطيه داخليا هناك علامه
سؤال علامه استفهام حول
ماهيه ديمقراطيه في اسرائيل هذا هو الخلاف
السياسي الكبير التي موجود اليوم في هذه
البلاد هناك اغلبيه لحكومه تريد ان تلغي
ديمقراطيه داخليا في حدثا الفلسطينيين هنا
وبالفعل اعتقد انه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
يميني بامتياز لا يعتبر ان هناك فرصه او
امكانيه للوصول الى السلام ما جاره
الفلسطيني اعتقد انه في مثل هذه الحالات
عندما اسرائيل منشغله بقضاياها داخليه لا
احد يتحدث عن امكانيه الاوضاع الى
المفاوضات
واستراتيجيا هذا خطا كبير ولكن يجب ان
اعترف بالواقع
موضوع السلام او عمليه السلام ليس مطروحا
على جدول الاسرائيلي الداخلي اليوم طيب
وضحت الفكره واضح وصريح سيدي وقف شكرا
جزيلا على حضوركما من رام الله محمد هواش
المحلل السياسي ومن حيث
المحلل السياسي شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات